[Applause]
the next
food that black people are gonna take is
avocado toast you think yeah we're gonna
take that
why you think it's like it's just
becoming so powerful the same way how we
took over uh hummus
yeah we're taking avocado toast next
you're gonna take avocados it's so funny
you took over hummus we didn't even know
until camp was on the podcast black
people like hummus no i love hummus
i've loved hobbies before kev said that
yeah so you think avocado toast is your
next [ __ ] it's the next [ __ ] okay
okay and why what is what is your what
is your nothing it's
healthy it's nutritious it's delicious
it's delicious mm-hmm
something like people be on to some food
sometimes we ain't giving him credit but
pumpkin is fantastic
we act like it's not every november
you're getting some pumpkin can we be
honest
if we're being honest might feel the
best at food i think so
i really think so if we're being honest
who is the best at food if we're being
honest with ourselves if we're truly
being honest
how do you mean that do you mean like
who has like the best restaurant it's a
white guy or like cuisine
white cuisine is the best i think white
people
are the okay who can jump the highest
white people no we can jump down doing
the thing here
no no no no no no no no no who can you
jump to highest black people right
okay no i think what black people have
in their jumping ability white people
having their tongue
yeah dude yeah no no i believe this they
can taste incredibly specific things
because their food has so little flavor
exactly i have to identify all of it but
keep going though keep going on this
that's right you guys need all this
flavor because y'all don't got the
sensitive
tongue you were like oh your chicken's
so bland it's like now you don't you
don't know the little
you don't know that little flavor out
here like you don't know that little
tiny bit of flavor like
it's that simple white people know
differences between water
like think about that think about that
oh i don't like evian
why not oh it's different it has flavor
within water
you i listen it's hard for me to explain
this to non-white but like i'm gonna try
bro
listen let me tell y'all listen when we
go
oh my god that's too hot that's too
whatever we have the most sensitive
tongue like that but that's why your
cuisine is whack because you can't your
your tongue is too sensitive no but you
have to make it for this sensitive
aspect but what happens when we make
cuisine for everybody else
when we figure out what it is you like
right yeah listen we
we use cuisine that's how white people
control the world they use cuisine right
black people are all angry because they
shot the black guy on the street what do
we do a week later
popeye's chicken sandwich let's go they
dropped that chicken sandwich then
you're about to ruin the chicken
sandwich right now
drop that chicken sandwich on y'all bro
that's what white people wait for
dog you know they dropped that chicken
sandwich
whoa we got another chicken sandwich
right now for aubry go on right now go
on right now and see people fighting
outside of popeyes you can see all over
twitter oh there's nobody fighting
outside you don't think they're fighting
out of papaya hold on
hold on hold on popcorn starts doing
delivery tomorrow though
hold on hold on hold on they're not that
crazy we're on ubereats yeah okay
they're not fighting outside popeyes
[Music]
i'm sure they're fighting i think this
is how they order bruh
oh this is just a roast he just roasted
everybody in the car that's amazing it
sounds like popeyes
exactly that's popeyes bro but ain't
nothing changed they ain't got that
stuff
that's a fight that's just a normal
normal damn pop-up yeah son it sounds
like someone disrespected that girl's
girl
and so they had to go in so they went in
so they went
and they put the new chicken sandwich
out bro
that wasn't even a papa look google
right now they got the chicken sandwich
back
then they've been had it back yeah
they've not they've reached they've been
had it right
redid it back they redid it it
who's the black guy fieri son
cisco
i couldn't think anything that was great
that was great holy [ __ ]
and that's dog song right there ain't
nothing god fearing me that comes close
to dogs on
so i'm just saying you got to put some
respect on white people's tongues bro
white people cuisine bro
your tongue is incredibly sensitive
that's why your food is gotta box yeah
no no no that's exactly what's your
point [ __ ] on it
that's what i did you had a point i took
a [ __ ] on it son you have a sensitive
tongue
you have a sensitive
curry for dinner did you what'd you have
i honestly don't remember yeah you don't
remember do you
it was so big chipotle yeah yeah
yeah that's white people doing mexican
food
stupid [ __ ] dummy
it is white people doing mexican food
yeah
yeah who's the white cook at chipotle
honestly everybody's food is mexican i
don't give a [ __ ] what kind of cuisine
it is
that [ __ ] is messed up so who's cooking
it the person who makes the food
that's whose cuisine it is i mean
it seems that i'm just saying if the
person who makes the food that's kind of
what
it is what is chipotle what's it say
chipotle
american grill donald's owned by
mcdonald's owned by mcdonald's they sold
it to
a mexican grill though chipotle mexican
would they sell it to
who they sell it to you who do you think
bought it you got the most money ain't
nobody arguing with that
yeah if i want to sell some [ __ ] i'ma
sell it to white people damn you think
myself to some cheap ass brown people
undervalue my [ __ ]
damn right i want to get a good deal
damn right yeah
i want to make money yeah that's
something i could claim but don't claim
food y'all got it you have to be honest
if you look at top tier chefs
probably to have the most ways but only
because white people like that food
that's what white people desire
that's what matters like you don't care
what white people say about indian food
do y'all
no exactly so why do we care what y'all
say about recommending indian
restaurants to me and i'm like chill
family no
i recommend that one one that was good
which one it was
what was it uh the [ __ ] uh no it's
it's like a famous london brick lane
there's
it's called brick lane all right
right yeah but i didn't listen to you
until indians took me there i was like
i was right you're all right though all
right you're right and you know why it's
good because it's in london
he loves it's in it
bro a lot of indians out there you think
white people invented all food
i think if i think white people invented
eating
i think y'all were breastfeeding before
we came around we're like yo hop off
that titty have a sandwich [ __ ] crazy
i really think that's what happened
i really think nah i think that's what
happened bro
i think in india y'all were just sucking
milk out of titties bro like the cows
and [ __ ]
and then also hey cows are sacred
cows are sacred and then white people
came up and you were like nah
they were like nah try some rice or
whatever like you know what i mean
you know like come on bro like you know
you got some tiki you got some masala
like let's do this like let's make a
meal
the only tiki white people know about is
the torch in charlotte's building
don't come here with that [ __ ] gotta
admit
white people did create indian cuisine
you have to admit that
you have to admit that you have to admit
white people invented oven get out of my
face no white people invented ovens
india is an oven
he just throw the food outside walking
down the street in august
no be honest bro there was no chickens
in india before why people
we had everything you didn't have
chickens we had everything did you do
you even think you had cow
i think white people brought cows bro
i'ma be honest with you
i said you could smack the [ __ ] out of
everybody
hey bro keep talking that [ __ ] bro see
what happened puerto rico
what happened we took that electricity
because you all didn't appreciate it
y'all we're not appreciating it back no
you know why would we be honest about
why you don't have electricity
why that grip really broke you blame it
on the [ __ ] hurricane you played a
goddamn music suit [ __ ] loud you
probably blew the fuse before the
[ __ ] hurricane then a hurricane comes
through a little water you're like oh
the electricity broken
yeah we're not having electricity turn
on the [ __ ] music hey maybe i just
paid your bills
no but let's go let's keep making these
arguments okay go
best food honestly you know who has a
legitimate
claim to the throne and i'm going to say
this objectively as a white
mexicans bro yeah i truly
believe that's i understand i won't give
it to them but that's fair
i'm just saying that's fair as a white
and obviously i have the best tongue
and have the best palate for sure most
sensitive tongue god given
talent sure right god from god i can
objectively say mexicans have the bet
probably
the best cuisine you know most sensitive
is just another way to say weakest right
say again most sensitive is just another
way to say weakest right did you say
white people are weak
your tongues are i mean we're weak is
that what you're saying
yeah if you think that we're weak right
weak in the tongue
weak in the tongue yeah that's fair weak
in the tongue
right how did you guys get freedom
from us not eating your shitty ass food
not using your tongue to what
oh hunger strikes yeah hunger strikes
yeah yeah yeah
yeah but do you know what that really
was about your food sucks no
it wasn't our food uh-huh you stopped
eating your food
and we were like you know what they get
it
they deserve freedom they're no longer
being honest we fixed them that's what
they said i would love
to i was on the email to stop loving
indian food i would love if white people
stop loving indian food that makes me so
happy
we don't really like it you bring those
[ __ ]
big ass tortilla chips to the table it's
just one they don't even cut them in
triangles that one [ __ ] don't slack what
is it
pepper we take that popper we dip it
into them three sauces it tastes exactly
the same but they're different colors
you got skittles and sauces
why is spicy what is this [ __ ] bring
the [ __ ] sauces
they just chop up some onions and put
some food dye in that [ __ ] one of the
sauces
for no reason that's all it is you put
the [ __ ] food dye in there
it's it tastes the exact same we got one
big tortilla chip i gotta snap that all
the [ __ ] crumbs go all over the
goddamn table
hey you know what them chips are free
say again you should be happy them chips
are free not hardest for indians to give
anything free
son that's why i don't believe it say
what say what we give that [ __ ] from our
heart what do you give for your heart
the the [ __ ] the popper that's our
heart we give you free free food yeah
bro the free indian food is the worst
how come when i leave i have to eat
[ __ ] bird seeds in the bowl and [ __ ]
yeah that like [ __ ] liquid oh you
don't like a mouth freshener after the
meal
but why why is that the mouth freshener
like
you never heard of gum you know what i'm
saying
why y'all always want to smell bad what
is it about you guys
that's just so committed to smelling
horrible stuff
what is it about that it's like like
there's gum right there you could do a
chiclet and who made chicklet
mexicans bro i'm telling you i'm fine
mexicans might have the best
i'm fine with mexicans right y'all could
give them but say objectively they have
the best food no i won't say that
objectively objectively they are up
there up there with whites
can i tell you why people have got great
food objectively italianos
we all love italian hey hey
be careful this mike's expensive
okay um but well listen italians
excellent cuisine
that is great white cuisine anybody who
says is not his hatred
is like can i say as an objective
observer honestly okay
my background is scottish and german
white and white go ahead white and white
yeah poor cuisine oh yeah
poor cuisine okay poor yeah scottish
food
not good german food not good
hot dogs and hamburgers exactly
yeah not good yeah yeah okay not good
that being said okay
obviously there's a bigger thing at play
here
you know what i mean like we you know
white people got to diversify what we're
good at
you know italians are going to do the
food thing right
scots are going to do i don't know what
we're good at
and germans you know we're not going to
mention
these [ __ ] be engineers oh yeah
these [ __ ] be engineering
with so many solutions bro i don't know
if you need another one
after to be honest with you i don't
think you need another after
i think i think mexicans just came you
know what they say third right's a charm